this video was made possible by
curiosity stream when you sign up at the
link in the description you'll also get
access to nebula the streaming video
platform that Wendover is a part of
there are few sports as expensive as
skiing a daily lift to get a loan
typically cost more than $100 with top
resorts such as Vail charging up to two
hundred and nine dollars for a day
scheme it'd be easy to call this a
ripoff after all all those two hundred
nine dollars are getting you is access
along with thousands of other people to
one of 32 lifts between the hours of
8:30 a.m. and 3:30 p.m. does it really
cost that much for a resort to run a few
lifts well the short answer is sort of
ski lifts are a simple enough concept
with the most common design chairs each
with a capacity between one and eight
are connected to a continuously rotating
cable pulled by motors at the top or
bottom of the lift between all the
redundancies and safety systems though
they end up being fairly complex
machines and complex means expensive
well it varies widely depending on
length capacity specifications and
location costs for the construction of a
new lift alone regularly reached 10
million dollars and most large ski
resorts have dozens of lifts in vales
case once again they have 32 that means
that even if they were all the kinds of
lifts that cost 10 million dollars which
they're not that would total to 320
million dollars
those 320 million dollars are divided by
a lift lifespan of a few dozen years
then divided further by the hundreds of
thousands of yearly visitors who are
each paying up to hundreds of dollars
per day and you can start to see pretty
quickly that it is not because of
building lifts that skiing is expensive
the paradox of ski resorts is that
buying and installing ski lifts which
are their primary physical assets only
represents a small proportion of their
costs actually running ski lifts is
trickier but for a slightly unexpected
reason between working the line scanning
tickets helping writers load and mating
the terminal to stop the lift in case of
accident a good number of workers are
needed to operate each lift then when
you add in all the restaurants ticket
sales rental shop
stores hotels activities and everything
else a large Resort has it needs
thousands of employees but getting such
huge numbers of workers is quite tough
the nature of the majority of these jobs
is that they're low-wage and seasonal
that means that a resort needs to find a
subset of people who are willing to move
to the mountain for five or six months
and work for not much there are not many
people who want to do that and among
those who are they're typically young
people who will only work a season or
two before entering a longer term career
running a ski resort is an enormous and
never-ending recruiting mission and many
are unable to fill all their positions
even when touting significantly better
benefits than most other entry-level
jobs at least in the u.s. like health
care transit passes 401ks and free ski
passes this labor scarcity has pushed
wages up for ski jobs but even with
higher wages they run into another issue
housing the nature of the ski resorts
economy is that the towns that ski
resorts are in need to be able to
accommodate a seasonal doubling or
tripling or quadrupling of their
population couple that with the fact the
resorts enemy nestled in the mountains
where there is little flat or semi flat
land where one can build cheap housing
and the urban geography of these areas
is wacky take the example of Aspen Aspen
is home to four ski areas operated by
the Aspen Skiing company and therefore
in the winter the greater Aspen area is
also home to thousands of seasonal
workers many of these workers are paid
the company's base wage of 1350 an hour
however Aspen also happens to be one of
the world's most expensive real estate
markets the reason for that is as usual
a byproduct of supply and demand housing
supply is quite low as the town is
nestled at the end of a mountain valley
within the winter only one Road in or
out housing supply for small apartments
is even lower the average price per
square foot of a home in Aspen is nearly
$1,700 in comparison in Manhattan New
York it's under $1,400 of course no
matter how much they pay Aspen Skiing
company isn't going to get workers
unless
they have somewhere to live while prices
decrease as one descends down Valley for
the most part there would be no chance
of housing thousands of low-wage workers
using the free market so Aspen's King
company's solution is to provide
subsidized employee housing at prices
that all their workers can't afford so
wall a ski resort may be able to pay
their employees 1350 an hour their
employees cost them quite a bit more
than that there is however another
unique byproduct of the ski town labor
market the masses of seasonal workers
often don't bring cars with them so they
need ways to get around now the u.s. is
not known for its public transportation
systems and it's known even less for its
rural public transportation systems but
American ski towns are often an
exception to this many have public
transportation systems that rival those
of big cities Colorado home to many of
the u.s. is most popular ski resorts
leaves the nation in terms of ridership
on its rural transportation systems of
these the system with the highest
ridership is Aspen's with more than 5
million passengers per year that's
remarkable for a town of 7,000 even
though this is time extends far beyond
and its core routes have buses every 12
minutes or more again rivaling many
routes in big cities this system much
like those of all of Colorado ski towns
is crucial to get workers in and out of
the area and it represents a symbiotic
relationship ski resorts and the towns
they're located in often have ski
resorts need their ski towns to set
themselves up in a way that's
accommodating for their workers and
guests while ski towns need ski resorts
in order to stay ski towns but here's
something strange
most big ski resorts at least in the
u.s. don't actually own the land they
operate on it's government land and the
resorts only hold permits to use the
land this means that the land upon which
one skis is public land and so with some
restrictions anyone can use the land or
garlis of whether or not they have a
lift ticket at American resorts sitting
on US Forest Service lands of which
there are 122 people legally can and do
hike uphill and
without a pass therefore technically
what the resorts are selling is access
to the lifts themselves not the
mountains despite this though people
obviously wouldn't pay to ride those
lifts up unless the skiing down was good
so resorts spend huge amounts of money
building and maintaining the downhill
runs some of this only needs to happen
once a year like trimming any trees
trying to grow in the middle of runs in
summer while some needs to happen every
night snow quality can vary alot and
without attention can get bad quickly
too therefore every night snow cats go
out to groom the easier and more
frequent it runs but sometimes grooming
isn't enough to keep snow quality good
sometimes there just isn't enough snow
the one solution to that
aside from waiting is snow making there
are many different designs of snow guns
but they all essentially work the same
way they spray out tiny droplets of
water that quickly freeze of course that
still requires temperatures to be below
freezing but this is common in nighttime
in even more temperate areas some
resorts especially smaller ones in
warmer locations rely almost fully on
artificial snow while larger resorts use
it to extend their season or build up
snow back on high use areas there are
though disadvantages to this from the
ski resorts perspective the main one is
that it's hugely expensive constructing
a system over a vast mountain area is
expensive sourcing the large quantities
of water needed is difficult and then
the process itself is extremely energy
intensive exact costs vary given the
number of variables involved but in
general snow making enough to cover an
acre of terrain cost an average of five
thousand dollars that means that to
fully cover one of the largest resorts
like Whistler Blackcomb in snow it would
cost more than forty million dollars and
of course all of that can melt in a few
warm days in practice though none of the
larger resorts rely so heavily on
artificial snow at least right now but
snow making still represents a huge cost
for resorts large and
the snow sports business is
understandably one of the most
threatened industries by climate change
and the rising temperatures it can bring
now the projected effects of climate
change on mountainous areas are
complicated it's not as simple as saying
that temperatures are going to be higher
and therefore it will snow less in some
places the change in global climate will
actually bring more precipitation and
therefore more snow in most though it's
the opposite lower altitude and more
southern resorts especially it will see
their season lengths shrink and shrink
and shrink eventually and many of these
the number of days they stay open will
not be enough to pay the bills
especially as the use of expensive snow
making increases higher altitude and
more northern resorts will actually
likely benefit from this at least in the
short term as more people travel to them
faced with fewer alternatives looking at
what's to come the industry has become
cognizant of this storm ahead and
started to make changes to address its
primary threat while some are physical
changes like building more snow making
capacity most are changes to the way
they do business money can overcome
nature at least for a while so what
they're doing is making sure the money's
still coming in consequently the North
American ski industry has seen massive
consolidation in recent years this trend
only started in earnest five years ago
when Vail Resorts the company that owns
Vail went on a spending spree in 2015
the company owned 11 resorts now five
years later they own 37 the link this
has to climate change is that now
Vail Resorts which is a public company
has property spread out across different
climates so for example if there's a bad
snow year in the Rockies they always
have properties in British Columbia
where the snow might be better they even
own resorts in Australia so Vail spins
lifts somewhere on earth nearly
year-round not to be outdone Aspen
Skiing company which runs the four
famous Aspen area resorts teamed up with
ksl Capital Partners a private equity
firm in 2018 and formed a joint venture
to compete against Vail altaïr
Mountain Company Altera now owns a more
modest 15 resorts across the u.s. in
Canada with the resorts they own and
partner with both of these companies or
leased offerings that are changing the
financial formula of the ski industry
for Vail it's the epic pass for Altera
it's the icon pass but for both of them
these are essentially season passes that
instead of working at just one place
work at dozens of resorts worldwide this
is a killer competitive move against
independent resorts since in many ways
these are better for the consumer and
better for the company the consumer gets
a variety and flexibility at prices not
much different than single resort season
passes while the companies are selling
more season passes which is exactly what
they want
that's because season passes hedge risk
even though they'll make more money in a
day from someone buying a single day
pass those buying those day passes are
highly weather dependent if there's tons
of snow they'll send tons of day passes
if there's little snow they'll sell
barely any nobody wants their quarterly
earning reports to depend too much on
the weather especially as it's getting
worse and so by getting more of their
customers onto season passes which are
typically sold before the start of the
season when there are a few indications
of the season snowfall the consumer is
sharing the risk but the company and
revenue variability year-to-year will
lower this is a crucial shift for the
ski companies as year to year snow
variation is expected to only pick up so
in all the real shift the ski industry
is having to make is not how they run
their slopes but rather how they make
money for them while they still might
lobby fundraise and rally against it
they're now at a point where reality is
imminent and climate change is all but
another components of their financial
plans
if you want a little bit more of the
action situs no sports and a little bit
less of the business side believe it or
not
curiosity stream has something for you
to watch next the series Jeremy Jones
hire follows professional snowboarder
Jeremy Jones as he attempts to be the
first person to snowboard down sections
of the Himalayas and shows everything
that goes on behind the scenes of an
expedition as huge as that this goes to
demonstrate just how diverse the
selection of nonfiction shows and
documentaries curiosity stream has and
they have even more through their bundle
deal with nebula now your curiosity
stream subscription if you sign up at
curiosity stream comm slash Wendover
comes with a nebula subscription to on
nebula you'll find all the regular
videos from loads of your favorite
creators plus a bunch of their big
special exclusive projects the first of
mine was the documentary we made on st.
Alena and then in a few weeks
myself and a crew are flying off to
another far-flung part of the world to
film our next documentary which will be
out on nebula soon you can watch this
plus all the other great originals on
nebula plus the thousands of
documentaries and shows on curiosity
stream for as little as twenty dollars a
year by signing up at curiosity stream
comm slash Wendover this is truly the
best deal in streaming and even better
it goes to help support independent
creators